one of the things we have to understand
about Benjamin Franklin is that he was
America's first celebrity he was the
first American celebrity but in those
days celebrity meant something different
it been being celebrated for something
in fact they would probably not abuse
the word celebrity so much as man of
renown but nonetheless Franklin's
celebrity her helped him first of all in
the colonies because it made America
known for great scientific achievement
his experiments on electricity made him
a World Figure just as his local
celebrity made him the one-two back for
philanthropic activities and so there
are so many people who are willing to
put you might say money and investment
behind the various things that Franklin
did because of his being known and when
you translate to that on the world stage
when he went to France look at what the
job he was that he had to do that he was
given he had to figure out a way to fund
a war to help a country win victory when
it had no effect of government and it
was mounting up depths left and right
and so he had to convince countries to
back this cause and in no small part was
that done was that made possible by
Franklin celebrity he was very well
known in Paris his image was put on
porcelain plates that ladies would
collect women would swoon when they met
him the streets were alive with
Franklin's name and there's one famous
scene when he was watching the first gas
balloons go up in France it was a great
scientific moment and as these gas
balloons ascended into the air carrying
human cargo someone turned to Franklin
and said what's the use of that and
Franklin responded without missing a
beat what's the use of a newborn baby
and if you think about it that's
Franklin's philosophy the small things
that he helped do with libraries with
fire companies grew into great
institutions of self-government
similarly America at that time was just
a small place a bunch of former colonies
with three million scattered people and
here they were declaring liberty and
justice under a new model something that
had been thought about buffalos by
philosophers but had never been done
before what would become of it it was a
kind of baby in them in the making and
through the efforts of Franklin and
great men like him it became an
astonishing place a lesson for the
entire world a baby that keeps growing
and we hope will keep flourish
you
you